hi everybody
i hope you can hear me
uh give me a thumbs up if you can good i
see you guys let's see i see them coming
through
um
so we're gonna get started um
um
uh okay so getting back to what we've
been doing um you know we we've been
talking about space complexity
measures how much memory the algorithm
requires or various problems require
and
we uh defined the
uh space complexity classes uh space f
of n and non-deterministic space f of n
uh the polynomial space and
non-determining space non-deterministic
space classes
and gave some examples and so on and
today we're going to pick up where we
left off last time
one of the examples which is going to be
an important one for us is concerns this
latter dfa problem so i'm going to go
over that again give a little bit more
emphasis to the
uh
space analysis uh which i got some
questions about last time
and then we're going to move on from
there and prove savage's theorem and
then talk about complete problems for p
space um it showed that this problem
tqbf which we introduced last time is
actually a piece based complete problem
but
all in due course um
a little bit of a review so we defined
we defined what we mean by a turing
machine to run in a certain amount of
space
that means it uses at most f of n if
it's running in space f of n uses at
most f of n cells tape cells
on every input of length n and
similarly a non-deterministic turing
machine does the same
but what's
in addition to that the
non-deterministic machine has to halt on
every branch of its computation
and each branch of its computation has
to use at most that bound that bounded
amount of tape cells
um
so we're going to be talking about
non-deterministic space computation
today as well
it's going to be
relevant to us
um
so we defined the classes as i mentioned
um
and the polynomial and uh
the p space and non-deterministic piece
based classes and this is how they uh
see how we believe they relate to one
another
um the classes co np and np as well
and of course
uh as i mentioned last time
there are some very
major unsolved problems in this area so
everything could conceivably collapse
down to p
which would be of course very surprising
but we don't know how to prove otherwise
um
and the big theorem that we're going to
prove today is that polynomial space and
non-deterministic polynomial space
actually do collapse
down to each other
and
being the same class
so in contrast with the situation that
we believe to be the case for time
complexity where we believe the
non-deterministic converting
non-deterministic to deterministic gives
an exponential increase
uh for space complexity it only gives a
squaring income
increase as we'll see um
so uh
any
questions uh on any of this um
or we will just march into a little
review of this latter problem
um
so
re reviewing
some of the notation and and let me
emphasize that so the big theorem we're
going to be proving today is that p
space and n p space are equal um
and also we're going to be talking about
uh
piece based completeness
but uh
both of those involve proving theorems
um in the in the first case uh savage's
theorem that converting
non-deterministic to deterministic
spaces of squaring and in the second
case proving that tqbf is p-space
complete
both of those theorems can be thought of
as generalizations
of the of of um
this
um
theorem here that the latter dfa problem
can be done in in
the deterministic uh polynomial space or
n squared space
um
so
it really pays to try to understand
how the proof of this theorem works
because in a sense this theorem is a
more concrete version of what we're
going to be seeing in those other two
theorems in a somewhat more abstract
form okay so
um i like understanding things in a more
concrete way first so that's why this is
a good example to start out with but
really in the end of the day it's the
same proof just repeated for those three
theorems so this is a really three pre
three for the price of one thief three
theorems one proof here so you're going
to be seeing the same proof
repeated three times
but in different levels of abstraction
okay
so
let's let's review again and
i know some of you got it but um
maybe some of you didn't and uh let's
just try to uh
be clear
on the algorithm
to solve the latter dfa problem so if
you remember first of all let me just
jump on ahead the latter problem is your
give a ladder first of all is a sequence
of strings
that change one symbol at a time
that perhaps connect go from one string
to another so you're going to go from
work to play
changing one symbol at a time so we gave
an example of this or you can easily
come up with an example of doing this
but uh
the computational problem is can you do
it can you get from this string to that
string and stay within a certain
language
so it might be the language of english
words or it might be the language of all
strings that some specific dfa
um uh
um
recognize um
uh recognizes so
it might be all of the string these
might all be strings that some dfa
accepts or you know
might be english words or some other
rule um
and so
uh
uh that's what we mean by um
trying to test if there's a ladder
um and so
uh the the latter problem is um well i
didn't i don't think i wrote down on the
lateral problem itself but the bounded
ladder problem is basically the same
idea you're given a dfa you're given the
strings u and v
and now
this is the bounded version of the
problem where i'm going to give you a
limited limit on the number of steps you
can take so i'm illustrating that here
so you're going to be given a b and you
want to say can i get from this string
to that string within b steps
okay
and we had a notation for writing that
going from u to v
if there is uh a ladder that connects u
to v within at most b steps
and so the bounded ladder problem which
i'm introducing because i'm going to be
aiming toward a recursive algorithm to
solve this problem
is can i get from
u to v by a ladder changing one symbol
at a time where each string along the
way is accepted by b
and only allowed b steps little b steps
okay
um
so that is the computational problem
that i'm going to be solving with the
algorithm that i'm going to describe um
so the algorithm i'm going to call bl
for bounded ladder problem um
and
here is the input
and uh the algorithm is first of all
going to look to see if b equals one if
i'm just trying to get
from u to v in a single step
in that case
it's a very simple problem because you
want to test obviously that you and v
are in the you know are accepted by the
automaton
um and they just have to differ in one
place and then you have a very simple
one-step ladder that takes u to v okay
so for the case b equals one it's very
simple
uh
for larger values of b we're going to
use we're going to solve the problem
recursively in terms of small smaller
values of b um
so
for b greater than 1
we're going to recursively test
you know if you're trying to solve the
problem can i get from u to v
instead we're going to try each possible
uh halfway through
we don't know that it's halfway through
so we're just going to try each possible
string
and we're going to test
can we get from u
the initial string
to that new string that
w in half the number of steps and can i
get to the final string v in half the
number of steps if i can do that
then i can get get from u to v
the total number of steps b
so i'm just going to try to do this
one w at a time for every possible w
this is going to be very expensive in
terms of time
but we're not worried about time right
now we're trying to cut down on the
amount of space that we're using and
this is going to be a big savings in
space
um
let's not worry about the division b
over 2 here all of the divisions and
we're going to be seeing this several
times going forward in the in the
lecture
we'll think of them rounding up and i'm
not going to cover up
make the notation look cumbersome by by
writing that every time
um okay so here we go here is
some candidate w string which is half
halfway through
um recursively test can i get from the
starting string to that w and from w to
that ending string
um
if i can if i find such a w then i
accept
and if i try all possible w
and i
never
manage to find a way
um to make both a top and the bottom
work then i know i cannot get from the
you know from the starting string to the
ending string within b steps and so i
reject okay and now i'm going to solve
the original unbounded
ladder problem by simply putting the
biggest possible bound into the bounded
ladder problem
and that's his value t
which is
gives the very trivial bound of the the
total number of possible strings that i
can write down
within my length m that i'm working with
so this is if sigma is the alphabet of
these strings
it's just sigma to the m that's all
possible strings of course that's going
to be a maximum size on the ladder um
uh
okay uh so now how much space does this
take and i think this is where people
got a little bit um
uh lost uh in
in the lecture last time so i'm gonna
try to animate this um i don't know if
that's gonna help or not but you're in
the end of the day you just have to kind
of have to think through how the re
how do you account for the cost of this
recursion
um
okay but the main thing
to start off you have to make sure you
understand the algorithm you know to get
from here to there we're going to try
all possible
midpoints and then
of the upper part and the lower part
recursively re using the space that's
the critical that's the way we're going
to get a saving by
solving this problem reusing the space
that we use to solve this problem
okay so
i'm going to i'm going to try to show
this to you on actually how the space
gets used on the turing machine you can
kind of think of here's the input and
then after that is going to be the stack
for the recursion if you're not that
familiar with how to implement recursion
doesn't really matter um but you can
just
think about what the algorithm needs to
keep track of
um
and so
as it's trying every possible w so you
know
just in order like an odometer um
just trying every possible
every possible string eventually maybe
it finds a string that's in the language
um that hears an english word one of the
first english words of length four that
you might run into um
and so now it makes sense actually to do
the recursion um
so that's all
every time you you're going to have to
have a register or a location on the
tape where you're going to be writing
down those different w's um so let's say
it's over here and and we're just going
to go through i hope that's not too
small for you to see
you know
that's really where that action is
happening um and finally maybe you got
to the string w now you're going to try
to do the recursion so here is um you
know as you recur
doing the recursion on the top half
again you're going to be cutting you're
going to be finding a new w
for the the intermediate uh
point just solving this uppers upper
problem where we're testing if i can get
from work to able later i'm going to
have to deal with getting from able to
play
um
good uh so
here again we're going to be trying
fixing able fixing that but the first w
we're going to try every possible way of
getting from work you know from the from
the start string to that to that middle
string um so we're going to try every
possible thing here eventually maybe we
find some string um some other string in
the language we get down to the string
book
um
and uh that's all going to get stored
you have to get you can't forget this
the string able but now we're going to
use more space to store those candidates
so that's a second version of w um
deeper in the recursion so here we're
going to be triangle
possible strings here again eventually
we get to some string book
um
and you know if that succeeds in getting
us
from
uh work to able via book now we're gonna
jump down to do the bottom half um to
see if i can get from able to play
um as a separate problem which gets
solved
in the same space so now um here we're
going to try all these possible
possibilities getting from able to play
maybe call is the right intermediate
string there
and so now
we're going to erase the book
and now we're going to solve the lower
sub problem in the same location
i hope this is helpful this is a lot of
work making these animations
um
and so
i hope so the point of all this is every
time
time we go down the level of the
recursion there's another register whose
size is big enough to hold one of one of
the strings
is needed
and that register gets reused um
uh
times as we're
um at uh
uh you know throughout as we're going
through through this recursion um
so anyway i hope that's helpful um
uh
anyway so each level of the recursion
adds another order
n
to record the w and so you have to how
many levels do we get
well the depth of the recursion is going
to be
how many times we end up having to
divide this picture in half to get until
we get down to one
and so the height of this
you know when we start off
is going to be um basically an
exponential
in m m is roughly the size of n
so when you take the log of that
you're going to get
um
you're going to
pull down the exponential so it's going
to be order m or which is again roughly
the same size as the input m is like
half the input because the whole input
is u and v m is just the size of um
and so
each level requires order n and the
depth is going to be order and deep
you know the log of the initial height
of this
ladder
and so the total space used is going to
be order n squared
okay so why don't we just take a minute
i'm happy to spend a little time going
through this either the algorithm's
correctness
um understanding the recursion or
understanding the space analysis if
there's any questions that you feel you
can ask that would be clarifying for you
um
jump in we'll we'll we'll i'll i'll set
aside a few minutes just to answer
questions here
um
so i've got a question here in step five
why do we reject
if all fail
instead of just one fails
um
well here
so remember what we're trying to do
we're trying to say can i get from u to
v in b steps
the way i'm going to be doing that
is trying every possible intermediate
string w
if i find some w
which does not work
that doesn't mean that there's not some
other w which might work all i need is
one w
for which i can get from u to w and half
the number of steps and w to v and half
the number of steps so i'm going to try
every possible w if any one of them is
good
then i can accept if any one of them
succeeds where i can get from u to w and
half the steps and from w to v and half
the steps
then i know i can get from u to v in in
the full number of steps
um so
i only need to find one
if i if one particular one doesn't work
i'll just go on to the next one
um
i okay here's a this is a good question
um
uh do we have to save the word book
so once we succeed in getting from work
to able let's say via book
do we need to save that word book
anywhere no
all we need to remember is that we've
succeeded in getting from work to able
we don't need to remember book anymore
we just
you know
remember that we've succeeded and that
is by virtue of where we are in the
algorithm so we but you know if we have
succeeded then we move on to the second
uh recursion second call recursive call
um so we found some way to do it so we
found some um
some intermediate point which succeeds
for this one so we move on to that one
we don't have to keep any of that work
anymore all you have to do is remember
yes i can get from work to able and half
the number of steps now i need what all
that's left is to get from able to play
in half the number of steps
i don't doesn't matter how i got to abel
in the first place so we don't have to
remember that
that was a good question though um
so i i think i i understand this to
before we replace
um the value for book
with call
the with the work involved to find coal
um
[Music]
yeah we have to check that we can get
from work to book and book to able
so we hang keep on to book while we're
working on the upper half
and only when we've finally succeeded in
getting from work to able let's say via
book then you can throw a book away
um
but while you're working on the upper
half you try book you try different you
know different strings of length four um
until one of them works
um
so
okay i'm not sure somebody's asking me
about breadth first search and depth
first search i'm not sure i see it um
this
i don't i'm not sure that's going to be
a helpful way of thinking about this so
i'm not going to answer that right now
but um
you know you can ask that offline later
if you want
why is the recursion
why is the recursion depth
log t instead of log m
okay well how high is this thing
initially
um
it's t high
but every time
we're doing a level we're calling the
recursion we're cutting t in half
first it's you know if you
you know i'm solving this in general for
b but we're starting off with b equal to
t t is the maximum size
so
initially this is going to be t and then
it's going to be t over 2 then t over 4.
so it's going to be log t levels before
we get down to 1.
um
yeah so somebody's asking can we think
of this as a memory stack yes this is
like that's where your typical
implementation of recursion is kind of
with a stack where you push when you
make a call and you pop when you return
from the call
um
is it possible that v can appear during
bl procedure on t
is it possible that v can appear
um i'm not sure what that means it can v
reappear
you know so i'm starting with u to v
is it possible that v might be one of
these intermediate strings yeah you know
um
uh this you're going to try every
possible intermediate stream
you know blindly including v is one of
them um
uh you know if you can reach v
more quickly
well great um
uh i guess what i have not dealt with
the issue of what happens if you
get to a
um
uh
yeah technically it's it's going to work
out because i'm allowing
you know the difference to be in at most
one place so even if you get there early
you're allowed to
not change anything and that still is a
legal step in the latter um
uh
yeah i don't see how to do this from a
bottom-up perspective somebody's asking
is there a bottom-up version of this
i don't
think so uh
but no i don't think so
all right why don't we move on
um
so now we're going to see this proof
again
but but this time we're going to be
proving
[Music]
that you can convert any
um nfa to a dfa with only a squaring
increase
so really
uh
well
let me just put that up put put that up
there um
uh so this is going to be savage's
theory that
among other things proves that p space
equals np space
uh so it says that
you can convert a non-deterministic
machine to a deterministic machine only
squaring the amount of space so you're
comfortable with this notation here
anything that you can do in f of n space
non-deterministically
you can do it f squared of n space
deterministically um
and we're going to accomplish that by
converting a
you know an ntm to a deterministic tm
but only squaring these space u's so n
is going to get converted to m
and now this proof is going to look very
similar to the proof from the previous
slide
um
it's the same proof
and um you know and and the fact from
the previous slide you know about ladder
really is implied
by this because you know we gave we had
an easy algorithm to show that the
latter problem is solvable in in
non-deterministic you know an np space
so ladder problem was easily shown to be
in here
um
if you remember you just guess
the
you basically guess the steps of the
ladder so non-deterministically you can
easily check can i get from the start to
the end
but
savage's theorem tells us that anything
you can do non-deterministically in
polynomial space you can do
deterministically in polynomial space so
what we showed in the previous slide
follows from this slide but this slide
is really just a generalization of the
same proof
okay
maybe i've said it too many times now um
so
we're going to
introduce a notation very similar to the
notation we had last time but now we're
going to be talking about
simulating this non-deterministic
machine with a deterministic machine
and we're going to have take two
configurations of this non-deterministic
machine c i and cj
and say
can i get from ci to cj in at most b
steps
i'm going to have a notation
very similar to like the notation for
the latter where i where i can get from
this word to that word in most p b steps
by a ladder here can i get from this
word to that if can i get from this
configuration to that configuration with
at most b steps of the turing machine's
operation
so these are two configurations now
um
of n
so can n go from this configuration ci
to that other configuration cj
but only taking b steps along the way
that's now the computational problem
that i'm going to solve for you with an
algorithm and it's going to be a
recursion exactly like the previous one
um
m gets its input the two configurations
c i and c j and one and the bound b and
want to check can i get from i to j
within b
okay so now the picture's a little
different um
but it's very similar so instead of a
ladder appearing here
it's really something that's basically a
tableau
for
um
for the machine n where i have a initial
configuration and an ending
configuration this would be hap this
would happen to be
um
uh
the starting point for the whole
procedure if you're testing whether n
accepts w but we would be solving this
in general for any config you know so in
that case i have the start configuration
of n on w and the accepting
configuration or an accepting
configuration but
in general what i
will be
solving is starting with any
configuration ci and going to any
configuration cj
so i want to
test can i get from ci to cj within at
most b steps
um so first of all if b is one
you can just check that directly um
you know and now again this is we're
operating deterministically to simulate
the non-deterministic machine
so this is the deterministic machine m
so m can easily if it's given two
configurations of n
and says can i get from the first one to
the second one in one step well that's
an easy check you just lay out those two
configurations
look at the ends transition function and
say is this a legal move for n
yes or no and you accept or reject
accordingly
now if b is larger than one
you're going to try all possible
intermediate
configurations
i'm calling them c mid this was like the
w from the previous
uh theorem
this is all possible strings c all
possible configuration c mid
and you know i don't you know a
configuration is just going to be a um
uh
so far so okay
this is all possible
look like my powerpoint correct that
seems okay um
[Music]
this is all possible configurations
which is just a string with a string of
tape symbols with a state symbol
appearing somewhere that's all it is um
you're going to try all possible
configurations as
candidate middle configurations and say
can i get from the upper one to the
middle the to this candidate middle one
and from that middle one to the to the
lower one within half the number of
steps each time
so um
and solving that problem recursively
um
okay
so i got a question here about the
possibility of looping forever
first of all if n is going to be looping
i don't have it i don't have to worry
about it because
um i'm starting off
i'm only i need to simulate machines
that always hold that are deciders
because i'm trying to show that any
language in here has to be accepted has
to be
uh has to be decided by some some
non-deterministic machine
so i'm not going to worry about machines
that are looping if they're looping
you know um
uh m may be misbehave in some way but
that's not going to be a problem for me
um so let's only let's keep life simple
think about the machine deciders only
um
okay so we're going to recursively test
here so that means i have a going to try
every possible middle see if i can get
from the
the start to the middle and the middle
to the end
um
uh if both of them work
for my after my i test them recursively
then i'm going to accept if not i'm
going to continue
and i reject if i try them all and none
of them have worked then i know there's
no way for n to get from this
configuration to that configuration in b
steps
okay
[Music]
and the overall picture i test whether n
accepts w as i mentioned by starting the
c
i is the start configuration and cj is
in the accept configuration
um
and now how big is t
because i need to calculate
a bound
on how
many how deep the
the the recursions are going to be um so
t
here is going to be the total number of
possible configurations um you know if
this is holding it never repeats the
configuration so this is going to be a
bound on how many steps n can be taken
and that's simply you know we calculated
this before it's the number of um
states times the number of head
positions times the number of tape
contents
tape contents and this is really going
to be the dominant
consideration anyway
and so
now each
recursive level and maybe i should have
emphasized this at the beginning how
wide is this picture it's big enough to
store a configuration
configuration is essentially a tape
contents
so that's going to be f of ny
so each recursive level stores one
configuration
now the w
costs f n space to write down
and the number of levels is going to be
the log
of the initial height
which is this so this is going to be the
dominating uh
part of it so the log of this is going
to be again order f of n
so this each one takes f of n space to
write down the depth of the recursion is
going to be order f of n so the total is
going to be order f squared of n and
that's how much space this uses
and that's the proof of savage is there
so
yeah so this is a good point there uh i
was thinking somebody asked can there be
multiple accepting configurations i
should have made the
i forgot to say this but and i was just
realizing it as i was explaining it one
of the things i should have you you can
enforce that there is just a single
accepting configuration
this is kind of a detail but so don't
worry about it if you
if you don't if you don't want to but
you can make sure that there's a single
accepting configuration by telling the
machine when it accepts it should erase
its tape and move its head into the
leftmost cell in the accept
configuration so there's just going to
be a single accepting configuration to
worry about instead of having to try
multiple
uh
possibilities which you could do in this
algorithm but it would just be annoying
to have to write that down that way so
we often assume there's just going to be
a single accepting configuration for
these machines
um
um
okay so this is
how do you know f of n um
so that's a that's actually a little bit
of a delicate issue uh
i mean if you could compute f of n
um the bound
which is for example if it's going to be
a polynomial bound you can just compute
f of n it's very easy to compute n
squared or n cubed
and so you can just
compute that and then
use that as
the size of the registers you're going
to be writing down
for
if you want to prove this in general for
f of n it's a little bit technical to
have to deal with it
and i'm going to have to refer you to
the book on that one the book tells you
how to do solve this for a general f of
n you basically have to
try every possible value from one until
it works um
and
i'm afraid that's going to
derail us trying to un decipher that so
let's not worry about that aspect of it
but it's not it's a it's a you can
handle general f of n here um you don't
need to put any conditions on f of n um
can we go over this term here
so we've seen this term once before when
we talked about lbas and and seeing that
lbas always
we can solve the alba problem this is
simply the number of different
configurations the machine can have
because the configuration is a state
it's a head position and a contents of
the tape
and this is the number of each of those
that that you can possibly have number
of states
a head position
you know the size of the tape of f of n
is f of n so this is that many different
head positions and this is the number of
d if d is the size of the tape alphabet
this is the number of contents tape
contents that you can have
um
okay
how is seeing if n accepts w with this
algorithm
convert non-deterministic turing machine
to some deterministic turing machine
well n is the non-deterministic term so
n is
we're converting non-deterministic
turing machine n
to
deterministic turing machine m
so m is the deterministic simulator of n
that's what this whole m is
so if we can
do this for
you know for any end that we've proved
our theorem
um
okay why don't we defer i think you know
we're
i think i got to most of the questions
here if there's other things we can save
them for the um
coffee break which is coming soon i
think we have one more slide before that
um
okay so i'm going to define p space
completeness i think yeah and then i
think i think after that we have the uh
the break
so peace-based completeness is defined
and in very much inspired
uh similarly to np completeness
um
so
a problem is p space complete if it's in
p space
and every other member of p space is
reducible to it
in polynomial time
and we'll say a bit about why we choose
polynomial time
reducibility here um so here's a kind of
a picture of how
p space or have complete problems
of
you know uh
relate to
relate to com their complexity classes
so
you kind of think of a complete problem
for a class it's kind of the hardest
problem in that class because you can
convert you can reduce any other problem
in that class to the complete problem
so here are the np complete problems
sort of the hardest for np here the p
space complete problems kind of the
hardest for piece p space
if any if an
np complete problem goes into p that
pulls down all of n p to p if any piece
based complete problem goes into p it
pulls down all the p space into p by
following the chain of reductions um
because any piece based problem is
reducible to the complete problem which
in turn if it's in p
then everything goes into p so
if
you have a piece based complete problem
which is in p
then all the piece base goes into p
um so why do we use
polynomial time reducibility and say
instead of say polynomial space
reducibility
when we define this notion
it's a kind of a very reasonable
question
but if you think about it using
polynomial space reducibility would be a
terrible idea
um
because
and we've seen this phenomenon happen
before
every two problems in p space
are going to be p space reducible to one
another we haven't even defined that
notion yet but you can imagine what it
would be
because
a piece-based reduction can solve the
problem
um for a problem in p space and then it
can direct its answer anywhere that it
likes so in general when we think about
reductions
the reduction should be not capable of
solving the problems in the class
because if they could
then every two problems in the class
would be reducible to one another
and then all problems in the class would
be complete because everything would be
in the class would be reducible to any
one of the other problems
so it would not be an interesting notion
what you want to have happen is that the
reductions
should be
weaker
than the power of the class
and so um
uh
every
um you know
and if you if you look at the reductions
that we've defined so far they're
actually very simple
you know the only thing is yeah they
have to make sure that they can make it
that
they can make the output uh big enough
but actually constructing the output
they would do very simple
transformations in fact even polynomial
time is more than you typically need
there's even much more limited classes
that are capable of doing the reductions
as we'll see
um so having powerful reductions is
really not in the spirit of what
reductions are all about you want very
very simple
transform transformations um to be the
reductions anyway i hope that's helpful
so what what we're going to be aiming
for in the second part of the lecture is
showing that tqbf is based complete um
and let me give ahead as a check in
uh
uh
so this is our first check-in um coming
a little late in the lecture
suppose
we have proven that as we will that tqbf
is piece based complete
uh what can we cl conclude if tqbf is
actually
not necessarily in p only goes to np
that's and this is irrelevant to a
question that's coming in from the chat
but i'll answer that later so um suppose
tqbf ends up being in np and not in p
what what can we conclude remember if
if t
is in p
then p space equals p
suppose it goes to np
what happens then
check
you know there might be several uh
correct answers here
to check all that all that apply
all right so we're near the end
of the
pull so let me give you another
10 seconds and then we're gonna shut it
down
um
okay we all are we all in
closing it down
um
here are the results so
yes so uh first of all the most
reasonable solution the most reasonable
answer is b
uh which i think
uh
most of you have gotten that if
you know if a piece based complete
problem goes down to np well np is
capable of simulating the polynomial
time reduction
um and so
um
any other problem in p space would then
also be an np and p space would equal np
but note
if p space equals np they're also np
equals co np
um
because p space itself is closed on you
know is closed under complementation
so that was kind of a
little bit extra
fact that you could conclude from this
as well
um so let me let's move on then to our
uh coffee break
and we'll pick up the proof that tqbf is
piece based complete
after after that
okay
so
so was d true or not um
d was p equal np no d we cannot
conclude that p equals np
um if
um
from p space uh equal to np
um
so if tqbf is an np
it doesn't tell us anything it's [ __ ]
for all we know p equals np but uh from
the stuff that we've that we know so far
we cannot conclude that p equals np
um
oh and yeah so you can conclude oh i'm
sorry you you can con b and d
are both
correct here
um
let me just shut this thing off uh
so b and d are correct so if if a piece
based complete problem goes to np
then np equals p space and equals coin p
so the correct answer of b and d
sorry i i got myself confused so c but c
is not something you can conclude
or a
okay uh
so somebody said
somebody's asking me a fair question
you know
i say the reduction method should be
weaker than the class
uh
but you know for example even in the
case of p space p space might be equal
to p
and then um it wouldn't be weaker than
the class if we use polynomial time
reductions
but
um i think maybe i should say apparently
weaker
as far as we know it's weaker
but we believe it to be weaker
if it's true if p equals p space then
every problem in p is going to be p
space complete
it's just going to be a weird world if p
equals p space similar same thing for n
p and np
um
so so i'm getting a number of questions
also about other possible reducibilities
that are even weaker than polynomial
time reducibility um
so we're going to see uh um
very soon weaker reducing
you know complexity classes within p
so first of all p space seems to be
bigger than p we're also going to look
at log space but that's going to be um
actually in thursday's lecture those are
these are called classes
ins that seem to be inside well they're
inside p they may be proper we believe
they're properly inside p but we'll
we'll see that later
um
let me just see here
really should have so we're almost out
of time
uh let me put our
timer back in fact our timer is showing
us out of time
so um why don't we um
get going let me
move this um
back to
okay
continuing
t q d f is p space complete so first of
all let's remember t q b f
um
[Music]
uh these are all of the
quantified boolean formulas that are
true so t could be of stands for true
quantified boolean formulas
and remember we saw these examples
from the previous lecture
that you know here these are two
quantified build these are two qbfs uh
the first one is true the second one is
false and and
it's kind of interesting to think about
you know here they're exactly the same
except for the order of the quantifiers
and so what's really going on you know
here
uh just i think it's
good to understand these expressions
they come up everywhere in mathematics
uh these quantum
quantifiers um
you know in the upper one
uh when we say for every x there exists
a y
that y can depend
on the choice of x
you choose it make a different x you're
allowed to pick a different y
but this but the the lower expression
says there's a universal y there's some
one particular y that works for every x
so in a sense um
uh the lower statement is a stronger
statement
um you know whatever you have in the
interior in
the quantifier free part uh
so the lower one implies the upper one
happens that the lower one in this case
is false and the upper one is true but
in general the lower
in the you know when you have this uh
change of quantifiers like this the the
um
the lower one would imply the upper one
okay anyway that's sort of a side remark
so um let's get back to the proof that
tqbf is piece based complete that's what
our goal is
all right um
now as i mentioned
this is the same proof
you're going to be seeing it for the
third time today but
you know there's a certain amount of
it's sort of
the context changes
uh in each case
so now we want to show that tqbf is
p-space completed so it's one of these
hardest problems now but for p space
um
where satisfiability was like a hardest
problem for np
so we want to show
that every
language in p space is reducible to tqbf
um and so we're going to give
polynomial time reductions that map
some particular problem a which can be
done in space n to the k it's a
problem solvable in p space
we're going to show how um
f maps a to 2 q b f we have to construct
the f
so f is going to be a mapping that maps
strings which may or may not be an a so
strings w which may or may not be an a
to
these formulas these quantified formulas
um
so
uh
w is going to get mapped to
some formula fee sub mw it had exactly
the same
even symbols we used when the proof
proof of the cook 11th era about sat
being np-complete this is a very similar
proof
but you'll see that we have to do
something more in order to make it work
in this case
so if w
you know w is an a if and only if this
formula is going to be in tqbf in other
words if and only if this formula is
true
um
so
this formula
is going to kind of express the fact
that m accepts w
which means that w is an a because m is
the machine is the p space machine for a
so this uh formula says m accepts w
and it achieves that by
building in a simulation
of m on w
it kind of describes a simulation for m
w which ends up accepting
and if m does not accept w
that description is going to inevitably
be false
okay so let's just see how that's what
that's going to look like
so we're going to use the same idea that
we initial that we used for the cook 11
theorem that sat is np-complete this
notion of a tableau
so if you remember that we had it was
basically a table
which weighs was just simply a way of
writing down
an
a computation history for mw
okay so the rows are the steps of the
machine
the top row is the start configuration
the bottom row is let's say
some particular
accept configuration such as i just
described where the machine
clears its tapes and moves its head to
the left end so there's only one
accepting configuration we have to worry
about
okay and each of the rows here is a
configuration of m of m
okay
um
because m runs in space n to the k the
tableau kind of similarly to what i
described before has width into the k
so now you know
we're talking about polynomial time
machines
so the f which is the bound the space
bound is going to be some polynomial n
to the k
so the width of this
tableau the size of these configurations
are going to be n to the k
how
high is this tableau going to be
well that's going to be
limited by the possible running time of
the machine
which is
similar to what we saw before
it's going to be exponential in the
space bound
so it's going to be d to the n to the k
where d is the
essentially the tape alphabet of the
machine
okay so
are we all together on this
this is um very similar to the proof of
sat is mp complete
the
key difference there was m was
non-deterministic
um
which might be something to think about
later but
let's not focus on that right now here
this m is deterministic
and um
but the important difference was the
shape of the table the the the the size
of the tableau was very different in the
case of sat is np-complete we started
off with a polynomial time
non-deterministic machine so it only
could run for a polynomial number of
steps here is a polynomial space machine
which can run for an exponential number
of steps
that's a
that's going to be
an important difference here so let's
let's see why
uh
the reduction
has to construct
this
formula
fee sub mw
which
basically says that this tableau exists
now we already saw how to do that
when we
proved the cook 11 theorem that status
empty complete
remember we had all of those we had
variables for each cell
that told us what the contents of that
cell were was
and then we had a lot of logic here we
had a bunch of logic that said that
those
all the you know those neighborhoods
were correct which basically says that
the the tableau corresponds to a correct
uh computation of the machine
um so why don't we just do the same
thing
okay why don't we just
build our formula
using exactly the same process that we
used to build the formula when we had
sat being
np-complete
something goes wrong
we can't quite do that
the problem is that if you remember the
formula that we built before was really
about as big as the tableau is
because it had some logic for each one
of the cells it had a set of some of the
had variables for each one of the cells
and had some logic you know for each of
those neighborhoods basically so he says
that each of the cells
does the right thing
um
so it was a pretty big formula but it
was still polynomial
the problem is that tableau
is now into the k by
d to the n to the k
that's an exponentially big object
so if your formula is going to be as big
as the tableau
there's no way you can hope to produce
that formula in polynomial time
and that's the problem
the formula is going to be too big
remember we're trying to get a
polynomial time reduction
from this language a
so we have an input to a
you know a string that might be an a
which is
we're simulating the machine
and then you know
the size of the tab below relative to w
is going to be something enormous
and so if the formula is as big as the
tableau there's no way to produce that
formula in polynomial time so this
is not going to work
let's try again
so now we have here
uh
now so remember this notation from ci to
cj in b steps
okay so we're going to give a general
way
of constructing formulas
which
express this fact that i can get from
uh
configuration i of m to configuration j
of m in b steps
whatever that b is b is going to be some
bound and i want to know
can i get from this configuration to
that configuration and i want to write
that down as a formula which is going to
express that fact and it'll be either
true or false
and i'm going to
give you a recursive construction for
this formula so i'm going to build that
formula
for a value b
out of formulas
uh for smaller values of b
okay so this is going to be a way of
constructing that formula in terms of
other formulas that i'm going to build
and there's going to be a basis for the
recursion when b equals one
okay so that's the big picture so let's
see how does this formula look
um
so let's
let's not worry about the case for b
equal one right now this is the case for
larger values of b
so i'm gonna the fact of that i can get
from c i to c j within b steps
i'm gonna write this down in the in this
way
uh and let's try to
uh
unpack that and see what it's saying
um
you know without worrying about
how we gonna carry this out let's just
try to understand at a high level the
semantics of this thing what he's trying
to say to you
it's gonna say well i can get from ci to
cj in b steps
so m
can get from c i to c j and b steps
if there is some
other configuration c mid
i'm calling some other configure i'm
calling it c mid
very much inspired by
the previous proof
of savage's theorem uh where there was c
mid was that intermediate configuration
so now instead of trying them all i'm
saying does there exist one
where i can get from c i to c mid and
half the number of steps and from c mid
to c j in half the number of steps
so if i can build these two config these
two formulas
then i can combine them
with this sort of extra stuff out here
and then and them together and put an
exist quantifier that says does there
exist some configuration some way to
find a configuration such that it works
as these formulas require
if i can do that
then i'm going to be good because then i
can
um
well good at least i'll be good in terms
of making something that is going to
work um
so first of all
let's understand what i mean by writing
down uh does there exist c mid it's
really
if you you know thinking back to the way
we did the koch 11 theorem we
represented these configurations by
variables which
were indicator variables for each of the
cells and we're going to do exactly the
same thing so we're going to have a
bunch of boolean variables which are
going to represent
some configuration
so
more more
you know formally or in more detail
what does does there exist a c minute
really is an assignment to all of those
variables that represent um the cells of
the contents of the cells of those
uh of that
configuration okay so now
let's see how to
you know how does how will the recursion
work
so um
to get this value here i'm going to
do the recursion further so does there
exist a c mid and now
um
for
getting from ci to this c mid can is
there some other c mid this is like
another value of w from the previous
slide where i'm getting again i'm
cutting the number of steps in half
again so i'm going from p over two steps
to b over four steps
and i'm going to do the same thing over
here
so i'm just uh unraveling
the
uh
the construction of this formula
in terms of um
building built by building it up
recursively
so
um
and then i'm just going to keep doing
that until i get down to the case where
b equals one
and when if i'm now trying to make a
formula
that's going to be say i can get from ci
to cj in just a single step
so this is really
talking about a tableau of height 1 or
high 2.
then i can just
directly write that down the way i now
the tableau is not very big so now i can
write that down using the neighborhoods
and so on that i did
in the cook leaven theorem proof
and this is how you put it all together
and now if you want to talk about the uh
getting
from
does does m accept w
so i initially say can i get from the
start configuration to the accept
configuration in t steps which is the
maximum running time of the machine so
again
you know if you followed me what
happened
um in savage's theorem it's the same
it's the same uh values
uh
now the thing is is we have to
understand how big this formula is and
if you think it through
if you think it through
um
there's a problem
because what's going on here
i'm expressing this formula
in terms of formulas
where um
the size of b is cut in half
but now there are two of them
so it's two formulas on half the value
of b
that's not going to be a recursion uh
that's going to work in our favor
um so let's just see what happens
so each recursive level uh
doubles the number of formulas
right going here we have two formulas
here we're going to have four formulas
and and so on so the number of formulas
doubles each time so the length of the
thing um that we're writing down is
doubling in size
each time we go to down the recursion
that's going to be okay if we don't go
too many levels but unfortunately we are
going quite a few levels because the
number of levels is going to be log of
this initial
um exponential size thing so it's going
to be n to the k levels and so if you're
doubling something n to the k times
you're going to end up with an
exponentially sized formula and
again
we failed
okay so let's i have a check in on this
but i'd like maybe we should spend a
couple of minutes just making trying to
understand what's going on here
because the next slide is my really my
last slide
and it's going to fix this problem
but let's make sure we understand what
the problem is before we try to fix it
um
why can we no longer write over each
layer of the recursion as we did in
ladder oh that's kind of a cool question
what does it even mean to write over the
different well
you know
uh
so that that's kind of an interesting
question here so what in a sense that's
going to be the solution
we're going to
uh
um
you know reuse things in a certain way
but but for but
i want you to understand that this
method
itself
does not work
because this recursion here where i'm
writing the formula i'm building the
formula for b out of
formulas for smaller values of b um
if i if i
do it that way
i'm going to end up
if i do it as it's described in this
procedure here i'm going to end up with
an exponentially big formula
and that's not
good enough
so if you cut the formula in half each
time even though you have two formulas
won't the length be the same
um
i'm not cutting the formula in here from
cutting the value of b in half
so you have to say b is initially an
exponentially big value
so we're going to end up with an
exponentially big formula
so it's not really cutting the formula
in half cutting the b in half and b it
starts out big
you know
i mean that b is this b is initially
this value here d to the n to the k
i'm worried not too many questions here
i feeling that's
that's that's probably not a good sign
uh
so if you're if you're if you're
well i mean if you're hopelessly
confused maybe i can't fix it um quickly
so anyway why don't we move on
and see how to
repair
this how to fix this problem um
and that is going to be by a trick
um
in fact i know
the people who were involved with coming
up with this this was actually this
proof was done originally at mit
um
and uh many years ago in the 1970s
and uh the folks who were involved with
it called it the abbreviation trick so
that's what we're going to do on the
next slide
oh no this is a check in first
why shouldn't we be surprised that this
construction fails
um
a well we can't
just the notion of defining a quantified
boolean formula by by using recursion is
just
uh
not allowed
so you just can't you can't define
formulas that way it doesn't use the for
all quantifier anywhere
or because we know that tqbf is not in p
okay see what you um
what
what do you think why can't why should
we not be surprised uh
i guess i could put in could have put a
d in there not surprised because
you're not you don't know what's going
on
so that's another reason not to be
surprised
but um anyway
um
hopefully you have some a glimmer of
what what's happening here
and when we just uh
almost finished
so i'm gonna
shut this down in a second
last call
okay ending
all right
so in fact the right answer is
b
um
i mean one should be suspicious
that if you're not
you know if you're not you're not
there's no for all appearing in this
construction anywhere um so really what
we're doing is we're constructing a
formula that has only exist quantifiers
so it's a satisfiability problem
so really what we just did
was we constructed
a um
we we did in a more complicated way the
cook levin construction because you end
up with a sad
sad formula only with exist quantifiers
and so uh really try one and try two
with the same
so it's not surprising that you end up
with an exponentially um big
formula as a result i don't know what a
lot of you answered we know that tqbf is
in p is not in p
we don't know that i don't know where
you
what's happening with you guys
uh
uh but no uh maybe that was a protest
vote uh but
anyway no we did we don't know that tq
and what does that got to do with
anything anyway so anyway that's
let's let's see how we solve this um in
our remaining a few minutes here
and
so here is the solution
he remember
this part where we're saying we're
trying to find c mid
um does there exist a c mid such i can
get from c i to c mid and half number
steps and c mid to c j and half the
number of steps
i'm expressing one formula in terms of
two formulas
that's where the blow up is occurring
because these two are then in terms of
gonna each it
so these two are gonna become four
become eight
and that's not good can i express this
fact in terms of just one formula
and there's kind of a little bit in the
spirit of someone your suggestions can
we kind of
reuse things in a way and that's what
we're actually kind of kind of to do um
so here's another way of saying the same
thing but with just a single formula and
it uses a for all
and the idea behind it is that a an and
is kind of like a for all
or for all is kind of like an end
just like an exist is kind of like an or
so when you're saying does something
exist you know it's is it this thing or
that thing or that thing or that thing
and when you're one saying for all it
has this thing and that thing and that
thing and that thing
so ands and paroles are very much
related
and so we're going to convert this and
into a furrow we're going to say
for all configurations cg and ch
that are either set to cic mid or to c
mid cj
the formula c g c h i can get from c g
to c h and half the number of steps so
you have to think about what this is
meaning here um
uh
and i also want to make sure that you
don't feel i'm cheating you because well
first of all
so now we have just a single formula
we're going to go down to the case b
equals 1 as we did before
you have to make sure that
saying
this restricted for all is is not a
cheat when you have for all
x is an s like we have over here
is equivalent to saying for all x
if x happens to be an s then the other
thing follows and this implication can
be expressed using hands and ors
um
and
as before the initial
um
starting point is going to be with going
from c start to c accept and t steps
and so the analysis
that we get is that
uh
because there's no longer a blow up each
recursive level just adds
um
this stuff here in front
um the exists c mid and the four and
this for all part so that's going to be
adding order n
to the to the
to the formula instead of multiplying
because we have two formulas
um and so now the total number of levels
is order n to the k as before so the
size is going to be n to the k times n
to the k um
uh or order into the 2k
um i actually had a brief check in here
um which i'd like you to do just you
know in our remaining few seconds
um
does this construction depend on m being
deterministic
um
so let me just launch that
uh i want you guys to get your check-in
credit here
but
in fact if you
uh
you have to think this through um
where
that formula says
that the tableau
you you get a tableau
is that going to matter depending upon
whether it's deterministic or
non-deterministic it's actually
um
well it's the kind of running 50 50 here
um
i want to just pick something because
i'd like to just uh close this out and
just get to our last slide
um so if you don't don't follow don't
worry
um but it's actually an interesting
point that um
the fact that this
um so i'm going to end this
all in
uh
so in fact the right answer is um it
still would work if it's
non-deterministic and this would give
you an alternative way of proving
savage's theorem so really this all
comes down to
this proof which implies savage's
theorem and that in turn implies
the latter dfa problem so anyway that's
side note not critical for understanding
really you can take those as all
separate results and and that's good
that's good enough
all right so um
um
coming back oops uh coming back
this is uh
this is what we did
and
um so each recursive level the size of
the qbf is not the same somebody's
asking is it the same at each recursive
level now we had to add in
um
uh
let's just see what
each recursion so you know we have this
recur
this is recursively built here but now
we have to add this part in front
and this part here in front
so the quantifier
you know
which is quantified over a bunch of
variables representing the configuration
that gets added on at each level
so it's not just it stays the same
um
there's stuff that's getting added in
but what's important is that doesn't
blow up exponentially
this stuff stuff gets added in every
time but not multiplied
um
okay so we're done here so anybody you
can all take off i think many of you
already have
bye-bye
thank you
you